does your girlfriend love sparkles and
rainbows as much as you do she doesn't
like glitter but she does like
girlfriends glitter
looks like you got here by unicorn i did
well listen this movie you know above
anything it really does celebrate
individuality and just being true to
yourself i'm curious jojo how has now
that you're out and proud how has coming
out helped you realize your full self
you know what my mom said to me the
other day my mom said to me i love how
comfortable you are with being gay
and i was like
me
and she's like well you're just not like
afraid of it and i think that you make
me feel better about it because i don't
know how to act around you about it but
you
you know you make jokes and you are
funny about it and so i think i just
embrace it and
seeing my i just did my mom's podcast
and i read some of the comments they
were all like i wish i had someone like
jojo when i was little it would have
made my coming out so much easier or or
like having you
like to look at now like makes me feel
more comfortable and so i think that me
coming out for me has just made me feel
like
anything is okay yeah
yeah
and do you feel like your peers and fans
have embraced you in that way too that
they've kind of evolved with you and
also accept you for exactly who you are
i do i really do think that i mean
what's weird is it was so
different telling my family and friends
versus telling the world telling the
world for me was the easiest thing to do
and i think that's because i just
knew that they'd be
they'd embrace it and that they would
love it and they wouldn't care and so i
think that
i think that's really cool that the the
world that i have around me now is so
supportive i mean two years ago the
world hated me but now they like me they
love you i've always loved you i mean
it's so fun to watch your journey and
it's really special because it's true
you know there was not a jojo cr when i
was a young gay kid you know there
wasn't a jt movie that i could watch and
feel like oh i want to be exactly who
i'm meant to be you know so it's awesome
here's what i want to know does your
girlfriend love sparkles and rainbows as
much as you do
you know what's actually funny we talked
about this
like two days ago she was like i like
stuff that i never liked now and i was
like what do you mean and she was like i
like glitter
i like sparkles and
all the time like she'll always kiss my
head and like i always have sparkles
and like her whole face shop like a
glitter beard and
i'll be like look you guys have glitter
on you she's like no i like it it's my
girlfriend's glitter like oh that's so
sweet she doesn't like glitter but she
does like girlfriends glitter there you
go i love it has she seen the movie
oh yeah she loves the movie she
loves it what's it like to have someone
to celebrate these big milestones with
in your career
it's cool it's it's really fun like i've
had
my mom obviously my whole life who's
always been right by my side and who i
love
so much literally
my rock for forever
and
it's cool to have love and support in a
different way
you know what i mean like i've obviously
had the love and support for my mom for
forever and that's the only love that i
need in my life
but then having this love makes it all
so much greater you know what i mean it
just adds and it's awesome so have you
guys said the l word
the i love you yeah
oh yeah oh that's so awesome oh yeah oh
yeah
well i know you both love theme parks so
is that where you're gonna celebrate
when the movie comes out we should we're
having a we're having a little premiere
a drive-in premiere i know and i think
that's gonna be really fun but we should
celebrate uh we should go to disney
that'd be fun we should yeah what do you
guys like to do there at these theme
parks
we love riding astro orbiters at disney
okay we love going on every scary roller
coaster at six flags
i haven't taken her to knots yet i
should take her to not over here we love
universal
we just like to be together you know we
don't we don't get what we do as long as
we're having fun well speaking of fun
like i said this movie really does bring
a lot of joy what do you hope your fans
take away from it you know i hope they
take away that
if somebody is trying to stop you from
being who you are
you
have the power to not let them
[Music]
get creative
was that a lesson you had to learn the
hard way
yes and no i mean obviously it's no
secret i was on dance moms
good that abby is
a crazy dance teacher and a crazy good
dance teacher um
she
never
didn't want me to be who i was but at
the same time she did
and i think that
that never really got to me
i never really let her there's a song
from the movie it's the finale number
called nobody can change me
and that song really represents that
nobody knows
[Music]
you